some students returning to school monday  will have some brand new safety measures  after series of violent incidents last  year schools are adding things like  cameras panic buttons single points of  entry  nevada pta president rebecca garcia told  politics now that many parents are in a  wait and see mode  the number one thing i'm hearing from  parents is show me how it's actually  going to work because a lot of things  sound good on paper but then when it  comes to putting it into practice here  in the clark county school district we  see that it's inconsistent from school  to school maybe one school has it one  school doesn't  you can catch the full interview and  more from superintendent jesus jarrah as  well this saturday at 11 35 p.m on  politics now